and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist how's my hair man I forgot to
check my hair before we do this video
and you're looking good
thanks man so good this is episode 167
today we're gonna talk about
collectibles nice all of our collections
we get to talk about yeah I brought in
my collection my collection okay me a
collection of nothing is better and
bigger than mine my less is more than
your less oh man alright a first
question today is from James in the UK
of course lots of things and such things
as maybe a book I've got a nice very
very nice copy of The Hobbit and I'm
wondering if I've ever read it again but
it's got personal memories and it's a
good decoration I suppose but I'm not
sure just how much value I get out of it
wondering what your kind of experience
is with such things and also like tucked
away in storage under my bed and you
know here in there I've got things like
old consoles and things which might
become collectible in 50 odd years time
and it's very unlikely because so many
people have bought these things but how
will I know that I'll never need them
again all right so so Ryan I'm thinking
here he said a few things that really
stood out to me first off he says he
said I have a lot I have a lot of things
yes and then he gives an example like
books and then he gives a more specific
example like a nice copy a very nice
copy of The Hobbit not just a nice copy
but a very nice copy and he said I
wonder whether I'll ever read it again
and he said something that really stood
out to me he said it has personal
memories and it's a good decoration I
suppose yeah and I'm all for having
decorations I'm all having for I'm all
for having things that trigger memories
but that's exactly what it is the
memories aren't in that object the
memories are inside you and sometimes
the things can trigger memories but if
it's just sitting there collecting dust
you know you're never
wait to use it then I don't think the
one book is a problem though obviously
right did he say was sitting on a
bookshelf I think it was like tucked
away somewhere he said what it's kind of
he did ask he said well there are other
things he has he said well I've got
things tucked away and storage under my
bed here and there like okay yeah he
said I've got old consoles which might
become collectibles in 50 years how will
I know if I ever yeah them again yeah so
it's it sounds like he's holding on to
something even this copy of The Hobbit
because it might be worth something in
50 years and I think it's you know what
the might thing it stands out right
because everything might be a
collectable such a slippery slope man
absolutely so I think just because
something might be a collectible that is
not a good enough reason to hold on to
the thing now let's talk about the book
for a second cuz the book was the first
thing he mentioned and then there was
the cascade of other stuff he said I
have lots of things right but start with
that book having a book is not the
problem even if you're never ever going
to use it ever again you're never gonna
look at it's just gonna sit on a shelf
the most collections themselves even if
it's a book collection a card collection
whatever most collections are relatively
benign and and I don't think the
collections themselves are the the
problem I think collecting for the sake
of collecting is the problem I think the
terminus of collecting is hoarding I
mean I there is uh when you see these
these shows or documentaries of like
hoarders houses it all started with the
the this might I might need this someday
yeah this might be worth something maybe
not even to someone else but this might
be worth something to me someday you and
I in the past it used to have like
stacks of old magazines because like
well I guess I'll reference this details
magazine from 2004 and and the truth is
that we never were and might it be worth
more now than it was then
yeah maybe maybe a few dollars more but
but what is what is your sanity worth
what is your calm worth what is the the
reduction of stress worth to you because
obviously if you're thinking about these
things their way
on you what's the psychological cost of
holding on to them yeah I mean for me
when it comes to collecting things I
mean I don't have actually take the bag
I do have a collection of books let's
say for example I've got a bookshelf
with some books on there so you could
technically say that is a collection of
books I don't allow that that collection
to go above and beyond that bookshelf
and there are times where like the last
time I think about doing that is what is
when James clear sent me a copy of
atomic habits I want to go put it on my
bookshelf I'm like oh there's no room on
this bookshelf anymore so I picked out a
book put it in the donation box and put
James book in there so you know I think
when it comes you have a process for
that when you looked at the book sheet
you were just like okay for me my limit
is this one bookshelf did you have a
process where you said okay here's the
one I need to remove this one is I'm
going to get more value from no it's
it's more about I look at everything
that's on the shelf and I and I ask
myself you know if I had to force myself
which I was forcing myself to get rid of
a book which one am I gonna miss the
least so that I I tell you what I missed
that book so little that I got rid of I
couldn't even tell you a book I pulled
off the shelf or replaced atomic habits
with Ella and I Burrell Ella my
five-year-old and her mother and I were
playing this game this weekend before
she went to bed and and it was a guess
my favorite thing in the house right it
was her idea to do this so she like made
us walk around the house look at all the
objects in the house and then and then
we had to guess each other's favorite
thing right and it was fascinating what
her favorite things were versus mine and
and we started guessing things and I'm
like like the chair that I sit in pretty
much every day like that was in my top
ten but it wasn't my favorite thing in
the house and the way that I thought
about this exercise when she ll I held
my hand dragged me around the house the
way I thought about what are my favorite
things for me is what are the things I
would replace first this whole house
just burned down today there's this
apartment building burnt down that's a
great way of looking at it well and so I
was asking about the books because it
was like what what are the books I I
know I would replace and maybe
those books you know you would never
replace and I guess for for James here
what would you replace that very nice
copy of The Hobbit or would you just not
replace it and maybe that that is a good
marker for me though that is a great
question ask my if this collection burnt
to the ground because it's it's often we
get people coming out to our events and
they'll ask us about a collection or
some kind of you know old thing that
they're holding on to and I will tend to
ask them if it burnt if you if it
spontaneously combusted if you walked
out of this theater and you got a phone
call and that thing spontaneously
combusted how would you feel and it's
amazing cuz sometimes people will be
like I'd be relieved and then other
times they're like oh yeah I'd be
devastated I mean that's a really good
indicator on whether or not something
actually is adding value to your life
well it's amazing that the devastation
versus relief is is really just a
mindset it's it's the story that we tell
ourselves however there are some things
that the all I noticed that all the
things that were like sort of on my top
10 my imaginary top 10 list of things as
L was dragging around house there were
all things that were very useful for me
and and enhanced my life so my number
one thing that no one guessed it was my
pillow but in fact when we go on long
tours I will often bring my pillow with
me and here's the thing I don't even
know what brand of pillow it is I know
I've tested a bunch but I know it works
really well for me because of my back
problems I got one for Bex and she hated
is like messing her neck up and like it
was terrible for her so we all have
these different needs as well and so
just because something works for you or
worked for your former self maybe that
Mahabad book was great ten years ago for
you but maybe you don't need it anymore
well did you know I was thinking with
James's his question specifically with
the Hobbit book you know he can do a
little research and anyone can do this
they could take something that they're
holding onto that they're collecting
consoles or books or whatever it is they
can do some research research and at
least get an idea of you know what the
demand is whether it's some few of these
left I mean you if you do a little bit
of research maybe you can get a better a
better picture on what something is
going to be worth but ultimately like
you can never really say whether or not
something's going to be worth something
and if you go into it with that that
attitude of well I'm going to hold on to
things just in case you know they
might be worth something one day then
you're gonna hold on to everything I
mean investing in commodities is just a
bad investment strategy and all the
experts will tell you that right we were
on Dave Ramsey last year and we were
having a conversation with him and one
of the first things they'll tell you is
you don't want to invest in precious
metals or different objects unless it's
real estate but but the the objects
themselves are generally bad investments
are there exceptions that of course but
when you look at the percentages if
you're looking at objects as an
investment unless you're doing this as a
full-time job and you're a curator it's
usually a bad a bad investment now for
me also those those top ten things I was
as I was going around my house and I'm
like definitely my boots my boots I wear
them pretty much every day definitely
these mission workshop pants that I'm
wearing these are like in my top ten of
things I would replace almost
immediately but my bed that I sleep I
don't even know the brand of bed I just
know that after trying a bunch it was
the the hardest piece of concrete I
could find basically that is something
but none of these things I mentioned in
my chair my Eames chair which I mean is
is something I sit in every single day
the chair at my desk is something that's
really comfortable and I sit in everyday
these are all things that aren't
collectibles necessarily I mean maybe
someone could have them as collectibles
but for me they have a specific use and
they they increase the value but they
amplify my experience of life is maybe a
better way to put that now let's talk
about let's talk about just in case
items because I think I think James is
maybe holding on to a lot of these
things especially with the might that
might is just another word for just in
case right yeah when he said we're just
in case it's worth something someday
right I've got things like old councils
or consuls which might become
collectibles in 50 years so I'm going to
hold on to them just in case is is the
implicit statement they're ready and so
there's a difference between just in
case just for win and we have an essay
on our website I'll put a link to this
in the show notes but here's the gist of
it really quick this is just for when
too often we cling to the things we own
just in case we might need them someday
of course someday rarely arrives and yet
we continue to clutch tightly to the
excess and our basement
closets attics junk drawers and storage
facilities just in case
the three most dangerous words in the
English language they encourage us to
stockpile our junk as if it's essential
in reality though we can give ourselves
permission to jettison the junk because
we can replace nearly all of our
just-in-case items for less than twenty
dollars in less than 20 minutes with the
2020 rule we'll put a link to the 2020
rule in the show notes as well so you
can figure out what that is I think
that's really helpful for a lot of folks
however there are a few things we're
certain we'll use in in a definite or a
definitive future right so there are few
things that are just for win items right
nobody purchases their toilet paper one
square at a time their soap one droplet
at a time their toothpaste one nurdle at
a time so what that's called
yeah you're welcome you all learned a
new word today I taught that to nurdle I
thought that to my dentist and his staff
last hours and yet none of them even
knew but it's great the reason I didn't
know it so it's a marketing term right
nurdle is you know it's like crest or
someone came up with it but yeah the the
dab of toothpaste is a is a nurdle but
you don't buy your toothpaste one nurdle
at a time so you stockpile it right just
for win but it's not in just the case
out we buy a small stock of these
products just for win we'll need them
the key to letting go then is to be
honest about the trinkets we're clinging
to just in case we might need them and
the goods we acquire just for when we
will need them if we do this properly
our excess begins to look a lot like
junk and it's easier to unload so Ryan I
know for me that I would justify holding
on to all the stuff the Jameses is
justifying right now right yeah and it's
so easy we have we can make up a million
excuses our mine I'm gonna and I do it I
still do it now where I'm like ah just
give it a little bit a little bit more
time and in there rules that have
me the 9090 rule is one that's really
helpful for me because it's just it's a
little bit of a check for me where I'm
like okay have I used in the last 90
days and a little bit we're gonna talk
about some of the collections that you
and I struggle with personally but the
this rule helps me look at those
collections and and say okay I need to
be able to be honest with myself here
yeah not anyone else because I'm not
holding on to these things I'm not
getting rid of these things for anyone
else I'm I'm doing it so that I can get
this excess out of the way yeah and I
just wanna reiterate to man that it's
not if James had to hold on to the
Hobbit book fine James hold on to your
how 'ok if you want to want on to the
[ __ ]
you know consoles fine but but like Josh
said be honest with yourself but when it
comes to any of these collectibles I
know in my life I have to set some
boundaries up so if James if there's
something there that you absolutely feel
is necessary to hold on to Josh and I
support you we also support you letting
it go but ultimately if you do have
something that you just can't let go of
then then put some boundaries up for
yourself too to help keep things and
check it sounds like it's doing a great
job organizing his phone and stuff and I
think that's what James is looking for
years looking for a little bit of a
organizational tip because it easily
want to get rid of everything right and
he also doesn't want a horde yeah so
he's trying to find that balance and I
think when we set those boundaries up it
helps us find that balance and a few
things here that he mentioned to think
about I mean the book is not the problem
the mindset is is the problem don't you
think I mean he said he said we say here
I I have things tucked away in storage
under my bed here and there that there's
a particular mindset that leads to that
the just in case mindset now he also
said though here's the justification I'm
not sure how much value I get out of it
when I say something like that to myself
it's a good indicator what yeah exactly
how much value you aren't getting out of
it's really because when I do the X that
little exercise the game with Ella and
backs and we were walking around like I
knew right away the things I get the
most value out of like there was no
question they make my life better right
do these things make your life better
James if not then maybe maybe it's time
to think about letting go and if you're
wondering how to let go for me I think
there are four steps on how to let go
because that's really ultimately what
you're asking here how do I let go well
the first step is understand the what
like what are you letting go out for him
it's the book right or the cutter the
consul's right ever again so what is the
what but then what are you really
letting go of it's not the book you're
letting go of it's this mindset it's the
the inclination the clinging is really
what you're letting go of and then
understand the why why are you letting
go this are you trying to free up time
for your health or useful more space in
your home why are you letting go and
then determine the how after that too
often we look for the how we're just
looking for how do I let go of all these
things but if you just know the how then
of course you'll just fill the house
back up again if you don't understand
why you're letting go and what you're
really letting go of and then know that
you'll never fully be ready to let go I
if you wait until you're absolutely
ready it's you're just gonna keep
waiting yeah and and and and it's funny
because you don't realize you're ready
until you've already letting it go
letting that thing go right exactly and
so if you were a hundred percent ready
you would have already let go right and
then finally the last thing is the
easiest way to let go is to not bring it
in in the first place and then going
forward what you've started the process
of letting go
be really careful scrutinize the things
that you're bringing back into your life
yeah because you never know when you're
gonna want to get rid of them in the
future they've got those things that you
bring in become a burden really quickly
and I'm reminded of this tweet you bring
stuff in man it's so easy to just say
yes and yes I'm gonna hold on to that I
mean yeah
letting goes artists part you you got we
got this tweet Ryan aw we're at the
minimalists on Twitter and man this
one's going you're gonna love this one
this one's from Val at in Valerie 5 says
a very good day to you all thanks a lot
for sharing such brilliant ideas very
useful for all especially for Rwandan
people so the val is in rwanda building
a nation from scratch after the genocide
of 1994 we shouldn't waste or waste or
misuse the little we
hmm and so that's really encouraging I
know it's funny we often get emails or
messages from places like Rwanda or from
Kenya hey can you come do a tour stop
here and it's like man I don't I don't
even know that's like going to a
monastery and like talking monks right
and it feels that way but the truth is
the difference between the monks is
they're doing that intentionally right
yeah and people in Rwanda after they
lost everything during kind of innocence
absolutely but when you're even when
you're forced into it or if you're not
forced into it you can then once you're
recovering once you're healing that's
what James is looking for a type of
healing and getting rid of this stuff
you have to be careful about what you
bring back in and that's what Val in
Rwanda is saying right now is hey this
is now an opportunity for us to be
really careful about what we bring into
our lives and realize that that this
idea of the American Dream isn't going
to make us happier right well James
would love to send you a copy of our
book everything that remains it's Ryan's
in my story of five years from being the
suit-and-tie corporate guys to jettison
everything applying these simple rules
to our lives and letting go of what was
not essential so it's everything that
remains it's a memoir about that
five-year journey and I'd love for you
to have a copy Sean if you could reach
out to James and send him the audiobook
if you like our podcast you'll love the
audiobook version of everything that
remains it's my favorite thing that
we've ever done in that book but also if
you'd rather have the book book version
or the eBook version James will be happy
to send those to you as well
all right Shaw we'd love to hear what
you have to say so if you have a comment
or a tip about collectibles including
advice for our audience today or any
advice for James as well leave us a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm well they're our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode is my favorite part of the show
so stay tuned to the end of this episode
for this week's listener comments and
tips Ryan what time is it it is time for
our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media we're on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram we're at
the minimalists on those
forms during the lightning round this is
where Ryan and I each do our best answer
every question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our quotes in one place
minimal maxims comm indeed all right our
first lightning round question is from
loda
our collectables best when they're
stored away or when they're displayed
yes it really depends on on on you write
what my snarky pithy answer is
collectibles are best collected in a
museum I mean ultimately they are the
best collectors of stuff best curators
of professional collectors right okay
literally went to school to learn how to
curate thanks exactly and and so here's
the thing if something is stored and
never used that's a form of hoarding
right yeah if I mean literally if it's
never used now if you're holding on to
something because well I really want my
children to have this when they turn 18
then maybe you have a specific use then
you might have might have to ask
yourself some other difficult questions
like do they really want this is this
appropriate for me to hold on to this
for this long etc but a collection to me
if you if you are gonna get value from
it the best way to get value from it is
to use it in some way now that could be
a beautiful piece of art or a bookshelf
but if you look at my bookshelves at my
house they look great they're like they
look like pieces of art a lot of people
have commented on our living room
conversations videos and oh yeah look at
this bookshelves they look great
well that's the point I want them to be
functional and I use them I actually
store books on them but also they they
they look good in the space as well and
to me that's the best sort of collection
if you can have some of that is useful
but also looks great and then I think
you win and on both sides absolutely
here's what here's what I would tell
Lodha getting behind the why of
collecting will help you hold on tighter
or it will help you let go faster
so really Lodha it's the ID of the order
you keep your things hidden you keep
them out of display that's fine that
that's to me that's not the important
question the important question
is why are you holding on to those
things and if it is a collection that
you find beauty and then yeah absolutely
display it but ultimately getting behind
that why like you were talking about
earlier it's gonna help us again it's
gonna help us hold on tighter or it's
gonna help us let go faster it doesn't
do any good sitting up there in your
attic your basement or under your bed
amen alright Sierra writes in what do
you do if you have a collection that
brings you joy but you are embarrassed
to display it we're talking about dildo
collection right Jordan was in my house
last week filming a where we were doing
this whole house story a home tour for
YouTube right and he was just doing the
b-roll section because I wasn't feeling
very good I mean Ella and Bex were there
and we were just playing around a little
bit and and I said how you got free rein
and he's like is there anywhere you
don't meet a film I'm like well we have
one box in our closet
it's it's a really nice-looking box and
it is full of sex toys which I've talked
about on on the the sex podcast with dr.
Christopher Ryan this is a great example
of you have a collection of sex toys and
you have you have a boundary set up for
it right but I'm also not ashamed of
course not there's a difference between
shame and private now is this to me it's
a it is a collection I don't even look
at it as a collection so I'm not
collecting them they're just there I
don't have a collection of kitchen
utensils either I have you know I'm
saying yeah then I collect your items
okay I understand what you're saying
yeah I mean it's but technically in your
drawer it is a collection of silverware
yeah I mean in the sense that we're
talking about for today's episode yet
you're not I'm not collecting them I'm
using them you don't have like you know
things in there that are still in the
package right and you're like this is
never coming out of the package no
collectors this is the star would not
even go there their utensils right and
their sex utensils essentially cuz I I
we use know that bands sexy Texan if I
and if I don't use them then we get rid
of them but yeah I don't maybe we'll
share that the that bit for the patreon
subscribers Jordan but the thing is like
I'm not ashamed of it and so I want to
talk to Sierra for a second my pit the
answer for you and then we'll talk about
it a little bit if you're embarrassed by
your things
either get rid of them or let go of the
embarrassment and there is a certainly a
point in my life where I would have been
very embarrassed by having a box of sex
toys especially as a minimalist uh how
does it minimalist like I thought you
would just have missionary and that's it
the the the thing is though like for me
these are these are things that we give
value from backs and I really enjoy
augmenting the experience right and and
so when I look at that I can't be
embarrassed by the fact that I get
enjoyment and pleasure out of sexual
intercourse with the person I love and
so I had to let go of the embarrassment
right and so it seems to me like cierra
maybe if you're anything like me then
you might be ashamed of your identity
there's difference between shame and
guilt guilt has said something about
your actions shame says something about
who you are as a person and right now
there might be an incongruity you might
have two different selves like I used to
I used to have professional jfm and
personal jfm and personal jfm wanted to
be a writer and I was ashamed of that in
the professional world because because
any bit of creativity in the business
world was not tolerated right any work
outside of the 80-hour workweeks was not
tolerated so I was ashamed and I
repressed it and it sounds to me like
you might have to deal with with the
repression otherwise you got to get rid
of the stuff that you're ashamed of and
hopefully that's not the case yeah ciara
there's no rule that says you have to
publicly display everything in your life
that brings you joy so you know all I'm
saying here is is that maybe she does
have maybe it is a collection of Dodos
and she doesn't want to those to be out
for her grandmother to see him I mean
that's that's totally acceptable yeah
it's it's acceptable meaning that cierra
yes ask yourself if you are ashamed of
something or if you're just trying to
stay private and if you're just trying
to keep something private I mean there
are many things and I you know we are
try to be as transparent and open as
possible but there are certainly private
things that that Josh and I keep part of
our lives and Ciara it's okay to do that
if you want and I think that the word
you use they're transparent is is
important there
there to me there are sort of three
layers of truth right that there is
there's the truth which is the sort of
first layer what's right and wrong and
then there's openness so so the first
layer is like I'm not going to lie to
you right right the second layer is I'm
going to be open with you about about
everything the third isn't gonna be
transparent with you yeah I'm not
completely transparent with our audience
so you don't know my social security
number but if I was a hundred percent
transparent sure I'd give you my social
security number well know someone can
that's something that's private
I don't allow cameras into my bedroom
while backs and I are going at it
Hey well please don't hack my iCloud if
someone did hack my iCloud and likes all
videos no I I wouldn't even be that
embarrassed by oh just be like okay so
whatever yeah I mean it's like I'm but I
don't feel the need feel compelled to
share those with the world yeah yeah you
did the other thing too Oh night Oh
Sierra is embarrassment you said it's a
sign that maybe she is ashamed
I think embarrassment also is the fear
of being judged and ultimately you know
might be a good test here like if it's
something that you feel like not even
feel like if it's something that you
want support on if this collection of
yours is something that you want your
friends to support you on then I would
put it out in the open and it actually
would be a good test to see which
friends are really really there to
support all your quirks you know your
imperfections warts and all and it'll
bring out some difficult conversation
yes are judging you you can just look at
them curiously hmm that's interesting
yeah do you realize you're judging me
right now is there a reason you can we
talk about this I'm really feeling
judged right now right yeah and don't do
it an accusatory way or argumentative
way you don't you don't have to be
combative but you can you you can be
communicative and you know what it might
even strengthen your relationships and
it might make them realize their
judgment and wow that absolutely that
all of a sudden they will let down their
their barriers as well and it might
improve the relationship as a result PS
Ryan we have three more
gins ice and here is my favorite one of
the day are there any collections that
Joshua and Ryan still struggle with I
almost talked about this on on that
first question but I decided to save
that answer for for this PostScript yeah
so that one is going to be yeah there
was one that backs and I actually had to
talk about and has nothing to do with
the box of sex toys
I don't struggle with that at all but
there is a collection that I called
myself out on and that's like yeah
totally you you do you do struggle with
that we were talking about this week and
so I'm gonna share that with you all
also sunita asks what are your non
materialistic alternatives to
collectibles and I've got a few answers
for that one I'm sure Ryan does as well
we have one other question from proud
mama she says what is the difference
between collectibles and not being able
to let go of the past my husband refuses
to let go of objects that remind him of
his childhood and it's making it very
difficult for me as a minimalist it
literally takes up our whole closet
because he won't let go man and we're
gonna talk about all three of those
questions if you'd like to hear our
answers you can listen to this week's
PostScript episode over at the
minimalist private podcast that is right
every week we record an additional
podcast episode and it's available
exclusively to our patreon subscribers
if we're able to well Ryan lets his hair
down a little bit on the Patriot I
listen my I get a blowout I loosen my
tie clip now my clip-on tie perhaps no
we we are a little bit more private on
on that one and we were able to to dive
a little bit deeper into some listener
questions there over on patreon so if
you want to support our show and keep
this podcast 100% advertisement free
then head on over to the minimalists
comm slash support in addition to our
weekly PostScript episodes the
minimalist private podcast feed includes
our ask the minimalists anything
episodes unreleased recordings of our
live events and the entire back
catalogue of past the private episodes
and once you become a subscriber you'll
also receive a personal link to our
private podcast feed so that it plays in
your normal podcast player you know the
podcast player you're using to listen to
this episode right now you can find all
the details and all the good stuff
including
additional podcast episode every week
over at the minimalists comm slash
support and here is a snippet from this
week's PostScript episode
[Music]
here's the thing if I want to go shop
for something like a jacket let's say I
mean usually I'll buy it from a retailer
like mission work shop that I already
know and trust but I even if I'm walking
by a place late and I know I want I'm
looking specifically for an item I'll go
there for that item essentially have a
list of one item or if I'm grocery
shopping buy only what's on the list
don't go and just say I'm just gonna go
check out see what's on sale that is a
way to have a collection run amok
without even realizing and all of a
sudden you're like man how did I get so
many clothes in my closet well it's
because I went shopping for them as
opposed to shopping for a specific item
[Music]
all right now it's time for our
added-value portion of the show where we
each talk about something that has added
value to our lives recently Ryan I was
driving around at night in LA it was
during the holidays we're gonna talk
about the holidays here is that cuz this
is the first time we're like back
officially and although you're in LA for
like a day I think right now dude it's
been a world we'll talk about that right
here right now but I was driving around
at night in like you know la usually has
a lot of traffic but during the holidays
it eases up significantly dude you're
like all this muscle this is must be
what it was like to live here in 1983 or
something and and what I as I was
driving around well I was listening to
meet Mills new album and the first song
he he does a his a sample of Phil
Collins in the air tonight yeah and so I
just put on the essential Phil Collins I
essential Phil Collins su colony mill
album it's not recommending the Meek
Mill out although it's good yeah but it
inspired you to listen to the Phil
Collins off yes of course and and here's
the thing Phil Collins makes the best
driving at night music period there is
and I think podcast Sean will agree with
me Sean as a fellow drummer and I say
fellow like I have anything to do with
it I've never even touched a drumstick
but he's a huge Phil Coliseum but
driving around and now I was with Beck's
and Ella and like we were just we're
just driving from the airport back home
and you know it's a 45-minute Drive or
whatever but you're able to do in 30
minutes during the holidays and man it's
just beautiful open road Phil Collins at
night the essential Phil Collins another
album I've been listening to recently I
got a download that man yeah it's it's
really good I think you could find it
wherever you you get music it's just
essential Phil Collins one of my fit I
don't know hi mrs. album last year year
came out last year the lead singer of
slow runner Michael Flynn so such an
underrated band one of the best bands of
all times a band called slow runner
they're from Charleston South Carolina
Michael Flynn put out and not the the
political Michael Flynn he's just his
name happens he Michael Flynn but uh but
uh
yeah the new one is called pretend like
and the first song is the lead single
from it is called greater Charlotte the
riding on it and this is different from
all his previous you know all his
previous music is sort of like sad
upbeat music which is weird like the
writing although actually a lot of it
just upbeat when he talks about you make
me sing to the houseplants or are you
making me Otto happy like they're all
these like really upbeat love songs on
here something must have happened to him
he must have gone through some sort of
breakup and man the writing on it is
just so gorgeous in fact Shaun maybe we
in this episode with with greater
Charlotte unless you're watching this on
YouTube then you'll have to click the
link that Jordan puts in in the video
but the album's called pretend like and
it's by Michael Flynn and it is just
gorgeous awesome in what about you
what's been adding value to your life
well let's see I just got back from
Florida my grandfather passed away it's
uh it's funny man it was kind of
expected in the sense that he's 80 he
was 81 so any any time that I have spent
time around my my home on my OPA yeah I
just kind of tell myself like five more
years if we can just get five more years
out of them Wow and so that's kind of
the expectation I've been having for the
last couple years so it doesn't it
doesn't make it super easy when someone
dies that you love but I guess you know
it just it takes the edge off a little
bit I guess but anyway being down there
reminded me of how grateful I am for
Mariah's and eyes process on keeping
track of important documents and being
prepared for an unlikely accident or you
know whatever unlikely events where if
Mariah needs access to power of attorney
or titled on my car or whatever it is
like we know exactly where to go so I
guess I'm gonna recommend I guess this
is technically two recommendations there
is an essay we wrote it's called scared
to death about death it's the
minimalists calm ford slash
death and it has a really good recipe
there on how anyone can prepare for for
death essentially and that's something
that we all have to we all have to
consider and we are scared to death of
even talking about death right now
absolutely and I know people who won't
even talk to their significant other and
so I don't know what position you were
in when you're going through if he he
didn't sound like he didn't have a lot
of this stuff sorted out right I mean
everything was okay the biggest I think
the biggest angst right now is we cannot
find the titles to the cars so that said
though it took us I mean I was there
four or five days and for four or five
days my aunt my uncle my myoma Mariah
and I we were digging through just boxes
and boxes of papers and records looking
for different things and we found most
of it except for the car titles but you
know I guess that brings me to kind of
the second recommendation is get a
filing cabinet get a filing cabinet that
locks or a lock box he had he had lock
boxes and he had briefcases that locked
have a place where you can go where all
that stuff is in fact I'll even add a
step further one thing that Beck's and I
will do I want to say once a year but
I've probably made her go through it I'm
because I'm morbid like three times this
past year I'm like all right pretend I'm
dead I'll just go lay on the floor you
know I'm like where are all the doctors
where are the documents where do you
find is that what she's into it hey it's
only for our patreon subscribers oh no
you know what we will go through the
exercise and jokingly yes sometimes I
lay on the floor and be like alright
pretend I'm dead now where do you find
the password to my phone to my computer
to my email and she has all of these we
have a spreadsheet of passwords all
there but also a locked cabinet with all
of our documents my power of attorney my
last will and testament my living will
etc and so all of that links to all that
stuff and you can use whatever place you
want to use I think I used LegalZoom for
all but not an ad that they don't they
never given me any money to talk about
them just like you've put uploaded to
the cloud yourself I mean right but we
have a couple links in the minimalists
comm slash death so that's a good place
to go so that you have a peace of mind
you're you're paying for peace of mind
and it's not that expensive dude in my
OMA like she even said she's like oh man
like this really makes me wonder how
prepared you know how prepared the
family is for when I go and it's like
helped her you know reminder for her to
be like oh I need to make sure all my
things are in order so yeah people you
got to prepare for death but I mean you
probably got a long long life ahead of
you but you still got to prepare one
thing I just signed up for is term life
insurance and we're gonna sign up I just
talked to insurance guy business life
insurance this year
because those are also things you know
it making sure that you have those those
things in order in case I were to die I
want to make sure that you have
something to keep the the minimalist
going and I want to make sure Bex is
taken care of and so having some term
life insurance is another place another
another thing and that's all there and
my file cabinet right and so Beck says
instant access to that if if she needs
it all right let's move on to right here
right now we talk about what's going on
in the lives of the minimalists yeah man
I see you got Christmas and New Year's
but I talked to my dad I want to like
start this catching up with seeing my
dad so we were just in Florida and my
dad came down because it's an emergency
and I'll tell you man it was it was very
hard for me to do your dad haven't been
communicating right yeah okay yeah sorry
I should probably catch people up on
what I'm talking about yeah so my dad
and I haven't talked in almost a year he
haven't listened to the parents episode
which was a while ago so just the cliff
note would be a year ago my dad called
me up and said hey just let you know
your stepmother showed me this Bible
verse that says that we shouldn't even
be having meals with you so I don't plan
on ever having a meal with me ever again
unless you you know he lays out his his
things that he needs me to do so he can
have a meal with me and
he don't call me unless it's an
emergency so this is where it started
and I was like that laughs because it's
sound it's so absurd it's it's hard to
not laugh at it it's crazy so so I was
like you know um I said okay if that's
the case then you know like I send this
long email like dude you're we can't
talk anymore like I'm sorry but when
every time I talk to you it is a
judgment it is a you're giving me
ultimatums
there's nothing encouraging about our
communication you are just tearing me
down so I do not foster relationships
when that's what the relationship does
to my life and you know like we talked
about the superpower we have now is the
power of letting go and even with you
know that relationship with my father I
could right I can recognize like oh he's
he's not it's not just he's it's not
that he's just not helping or it's just
it's not that he's not supportive but
he's the exact opposite so we were down
in Florida and I'll tell you man like it
was very emotional but what I'll say are
two things I want to get my dad credit
for totally being there in the immersion
in an emergency and yes they were
avoiding eating meals with us he I mean
it was it's really insulting but but by
and large it wasn't that bad that's my
dad kept saying this isn't that bad and
I'm like okay like that's that's fine
and we kind of had a conversation but I
guess what I really want our audience to
take away from this is when my
grandfather died and my dad came down
and there's this emergency situation in
the family the the ability to be
respectful the ability to be cordial the
ability to not let out all the visceral
feelings I have not be combative but to
not be combative to you feel like that's
what you want to do right oh yeah man
like it's in fact there was one
particular night that we had a
conversation and I yeah and we were
talking about all these things that that
you know that's been on my mind for the
last year and the other thing I wanna
get my credit for is when I get
emotional
especially in with the conversation and
especially with someone who I feel so
comfortable with I interrupt a lot I
it's hard for me to remember to be
respectful during conversations like
that and my dad was very patient with me
and he would even be like hey you can
say what you want but you kind of
interrupted me there I'm like oh yeah
you're right but I guess um you know
coming at at it in a sense of trying to
be respectful
not being combative I just realized like
I could I could talk to my worst enemy
if I keep those two things at heart and
you know we had some pretty good
conversations and you know I just pretty
much was like hey man I hope I don't
have to wait till the next funeral to
see ya you know I hope there's something
else that we can work out and you know
we're still working through our stuff
but but just that takeaway of just
trying to be respectful man like it
really helped everything be peaceful and
it really helped it was most importantly
it helped my myoma it helped her the
most and and that's what I really
appreciate about it so I think it's it's
good you were able to set that aside
because my opinion your father has
dropped dramatically over the last year
or two and we don't go in details in
public in fact maybe we could talk about
some stuff on on the PostScript yeah in
fact I had a pretty traumatic Christmas
and New Year's Eve like the most
traumatic of my life so I just want
everyone listening to this know that
Josh came to me on like December 26th
and he was like dude I had the craziest
Christmas experience I can't wait to
talk to you about it on the podcast yeah
the day that we're recording this is
January 8 I've been in anticipation for
the last two weeks I'm gonna save it for
the PostScript because I need a safer
space than this all right I just don't
want all the tweets to come cat we have
you hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people who listen to this
thing and yeah I'm gonna save it for the
PostScript to talk about Christmas in
New Year's Eve you just love you just
love making me hang on don't you I am
headed to Montana this week and so are
you
because so by the time you're listening
to this by the time this comes out
Ella's having a head surgery
so everyone think about her and send her
nice tweet she's at Ellis and which on
Twitter if you want to tweet her and and
she she says the craziest things we got
so many great tweets from her this week
but yes she's having head surgery and so
we have a good surgeon up there it's it
was a terrible storm when she was about
six months old she was in day care and
they were negligent and they left her in
this mesh crib and unsupervised for I
don't know several minutes and she's
kept rubbing her head against the the
mesh trying to scape essentially and it
it it looks like she has male pattern
baldness right here in this spot on the
top of her head a huge bloody scar for
months and months and months and now
wait to get a fix if she's in
kindergarten now and now is the right
time to get to get a fix because we
don't want her to feel ostracized by
other kids and we usually when you ever
you see pictures of her and stuff she
always says her hair up because of that
there's this huge bald spot there so
yeah we're we're gonna take care of that
this this week but I think it'd all be
it'll be great it's gonna be great for
her yeah and and then of course I'll
talk about my traumatic holidays on the
PostScript we have it's a new year and a
lot of people this is the month where a
lot of people start writing again I can
tell you the best decision that Ryan and
I ever made was the fall of 2010 we
started a blog yeah ended up being a
great financial decision for us to
because it led books and tours and this
podcast and what documentary yeah it's
funny when you say financial situation
though it's not like the blog makes us
money no and that's the thing it's more
about it gave us gave us a public voice
absolutely and it gave us a public voice
to those first 52 readers who showed up
which were basically just Facebook
friends and stuff and the first early on
the first year to 2011 2012 we had so
many people asking us like how did you
start your blog it looks beautiful and
and eventually we wrote an essay called
how to start a successful blog because
we
had amassed a a decent sized audience
several thousand people at that point
and more and more people kept asking
about it we just updated it for 2019 all
new screenshots and everything and if
you're interested in starting your own
blog if you're interested in just
improving your writing habit blogging is
the best thing to do just writing a
weekly blog developing that habit is
really important you can do that
relatively inexpensively or even free
and the WordPress itself is free hosting
it somewhere a couple bucks a month but
it's one of the cheapest ways for you to
create this habit and if you want to
step-by-step guide and how you can set
up a blog and in less than an hour and
don't spend the hundred hours that Ryan
and I spent trying to figure out HTML
and realizing that wasn't the way to go
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash blog it's called how to start a
successful blog and it's updated for
2019 that's out there right now also I
wanted to bring this up Ryan it's been 5
years this month since our good friend
Stan Dukes passed away we did a whole
episode about Stan we'll put a link to
it in the show notes if you want too we
had a tearful conversation a couple
years ago I think it was January of man
maybe that was 20 yeah 2017 something
like that yeah 2016 2017 yeah anyway
yeah but it we did a comment but it's
been five years now
and so we wrote this essay or I wrote
this essay when we were on tour we were
just starting our crazy hundred city
tour January 2014 and I want to just
recognize Stan but also we have some
really great life lessons from him yeah
and they're especially applicable to me
right now with some of the the trauma
that I've been going through and in my
own health so let's so let's read this
this is called live like Stan the
traffic light hanging above our car is a
blur of red the tears are burning my
eyes Ryan is seated in the passenger
seat next to me he too is tyria it's the
Big E it's the eve of our big hundred
city book tour the Florida Sun has
already set behind the Tampa Bay
nightfall is upon us and
by the time the traffic light changes
it's just a mess of wet green a
shapeless emerald cloud spilling into
the nighttime ether I received the call
a moment earlier the news a week after
Ryan avoided his own death there's a
whole separate essay about that and he
got into a really bad car crash a week
after Ryan avoided his own death one of
my closest friends
Stanley dukes pictured above is dead
this isn't gonna be easy to write
overwhelmed with unanswerable questions
I feel a canyon of sorrow I can't see
past the tears he was only 36 so I'm
compelled to pin a thousand cliches life
is too short every day is a gift
you never know when you're going to go
so live your life to the fullest while
all these truisms are apt the truth is
that Stan lived more in his three and a
half decades than most people could in a
hundred years
Stanley dukes was a mozart of positive
living and so his attenuated life was
not in vain of course this doesn't erase
the pain but it makes it easier to
handle we met in the corporate world a
decade ago at first I was a regional
manager at first when I was a regional
manager Stan Dukes worked for me as a
store manager but he was so talented and
he added so much value to so many
people's lives that I often felt as
though I worked for him although he
managed dozens of employees his genius
was most pronounced in his ability to
inspire people who weren't
self-motivated which if you know
anything about leading people it's sort
of like convincing water to be less wet
but somehow he did it always carrying
with him was smile and his positive
mental attitude as a result he was one
of the most successful managers in the
company I remember you and him Ryan
would always like battle it out for one
and two out of all the store managers in
the company for several years in a row
over time we became close friends we
shared similar values and beliefs as
well as taste and literature and movies
and music
I traded him my overwrought short
stories for his hilarious pseudonymous
erotic fiction we exchanged lines from
Glengarry Glen Ross characters and we
both shared a healthy obsession for John
Mayer's music we became so close that he
is even the first person who makes an
appearance in my memoir everything that
remains where he pops is a huge loveable
head into the very first page and this
is the short excerpt with with Stan
there from everything that remains our
identities are shaped by the costumes I
wear I'm seated in a cramped conference
room surrounded by ghosts and shirt
sleeves and pleated trousers there are
35 maybe 40 people here middle managers
the lot of us mostly Caucasian mostly
male all using apathy the group's median
complexion is that of an agoraphobe a
Microsoft Excel spreadsheet is projected
onto an oversized canvas pulled from the
ceiling at the front of the room the
canvas is flimsy and cracked and is the
shade of off whites that suggests it's a
relic from a time when employees were
allowed to smoke indoors the rest of the
room is aggressively white the walls are
white the ceiling is white the people
are white as if all cut from the same
materials well everyone except Stan
seated at the back of the room
Cincinnati's population is 45% black but
Stan as part of our company's
single-digit percentage his comments
rarely solicited by executives are often
dismissed with a nod and a pained smile
although he's the size of an NFL
linebacker Stan is a paragon of kindness
but that doesn't stop me from secretly
hoping that one day he'll get fed up
with the patronizing grins and make it
his duty to reform that one of the
bosses fish-eyed faces return to the
essay here of course Stan would have
never touched a hair on any of their
balding heads he was above that he was
above all the petty [ __ ] we get
caught up in everyday he was above
living life based on other people's
standards his standards were too high
for that he had character Stan
contributed beyond himself each year at
Christmastime he dressed up as
anta and handed out gifts to our
employees I forgot all about that right
now
Santa yeah he spent many off hours
donating his time to soup kitchens and
Habitat for Humanity
last year he founded a mentorship
conference for young men ages 13 to 18
Stan cared when I decided to leave the
corporate world three years ago he
didn't flinch instead he was the first
to join me he we walked away together
guided by solidarity and a kinship
that's impossible to manufacture before
I moved to Montana we met for coffee
weekly our visits yielded heartfelt
advice on women and life as well as
arguments over which album was John
Mayer's best heavier things our battle
studies Jordan by the way it's
definitely heavier things just so you
know Jordan know more is also an avid
John Mayer fan what is your favorite if
you say continuum you're gonna the
search for everything is your favorite
John Mayer album is it the first one's
not even an album it's for pits for
playlists is that the it's the brand-new
one oh yeah there's a really great cover
it's funny mines I think my favorite
ones born and raised man only because I
like it I like oh it's very month hand
album I was gonna say but Paradise
Valley is even more Montana yeah I was
gonna say my second was Paradise Valley
but that's because both of those albums
came out when we lived in Montana and
born and raised came out like right when
we moved to Montana and it was like this
affirmation that I'm doing the right
thing man we're doing the right thing
yeah shadow days the song shadow days
and there's one of my favorite John
Mayer songs it's truly truly great the
search for everything I it was it was a
rather just disjointed album like it was
all over the place for me I think that
was his intention though it's the
obviously the title is the search for
everything right oh my God we're getting
lost in the weeds yeah we are sorry uh
thanks Stan wherever you are all right
back to the text here everything about
Stan reflected a profound truth even his
simple tweets were steeped in profundity
I'm gonna read some of his tweets here
these are in the essay
we'll put a length of this essay in the
show notes if y'all want to share it
here are some of Stan Dukes his tweets
and these are the some of the most
profound especially in light of his
death a man can't walk out of his own
story
I mean he's blow me away I'm getting
chills secure your own mask before
assisting others and that was really
like I feel like Stan lived that like he
helped himself but he also helped other
people but he helped himself he knew he
needed to have the best version of
himself there to help other people
there's a bright spot in every shadow
it's the bitter and the sweet I know the
bitter that allows me to appreciate the
sweet man I've been living that recently
only your actions can prove your worth
they tell people who you are and finally
don't drown in conformity and sand fi
did not drown in conformity and didn't
drown in the status quo either countless
essays on our site were inspired by my
conversations with Stan our final
conversation was mimetic of his life it
was short but meaningful three days
before Thanksgiving I sent him a message
I don't have to wait till Thursday to be
thankful for you I'm grateful you're in
my life to which he replied succinctly
thanks for that know that I feel the
same Stan lived until he died he truly
lived every day not like most of us who
walk through life like it's some kind of
dress rehearsal worrying about [ __ ]
that doesn't matter no Stan was so alive
one of the only people I know who didn't
take this life for granted if there's a
lesson to be learned here it's that like
Stan we're all gonna die but few of us
will be courageous enough to live as he
did honest well-rounded passionate
positive and constantly improving above
all Stan Dukes was good people a man I
aspire to live like that green blur
overhead is my signal to step on the gas
to wipe the tears and move forward
perhaps you'll do likewise
I know Stanwood well thanks for making
me all sad my job I miss him so much man
me too I know that we'd be we'd be
working with him right now he'd be out
here in LA with us right here right now
yeah yeah he was 36 but really did live
more in those I mean he's younger than
he was like the older wiser version I
remember cuz I mean five years ago I was
32 and he was 36 and and I looked up to
him in many ways and he looked up to me
in some ways and like we were mentors to
each other
but man yeah I'm missing but I'm
grateful for the time that we had that
we had together yeah I want to talk a
little bit about some changes that we're
about to make coming up really really
soon we have some exciting news for you
all if you're a fan of our podcast
especially if you're a patreon supporter
but even if you're not patreon supporter
right this is some some exciting news
where we're gonna make some slight
changes to the I want to say format of
the podcast but the format itself is
gonna stay relatively unchanged so let's
talk about this this exciting news that
we have Ryan you and I have been talking
for the last month or two about sharing
some more in-depth conversations more
personal conversations so in in March
2019 so that's right around the corner a
month and a half away right the
minimalist podcast the one you listen to
right now the popular free public
version is changing its format so we can
produce some more meaningful and more
intimate private and personal podcast
episodes for our patreon subscribers and
why are we doing this you ask well Ryan
I've had a lot of conversations about
that and we've also talked to Jordan and
podcast Sean about this and there are
some topics that we want to discuss send
me privately you know like a stand-up
Kyle make you we will go to like the The
Comedy Store and some because some
comics are working on brand new material
and it doesn't always land but sometimes
it lands perfectly and you can tell
there they're working out some stuff and
and for us we want to be able to work
out some stuff and and work out some
some conversations some semi private
conversations in front of a a small
empathetic understanding group
of people you know conversations we'd
have with trusted friends and and and we
need that that group of trusted friends
and because our patreon subscribers are
the people who support our work the most
we believe that our patreon subscribers
are the best people to share these
conversations with not not the entire
world now we'll refine some stuff and
then it'll make its way back out into
the the main podcast feed as well and
and and to other creations but patreon
is really going to be the place where we
start having some in-depth conversations
longer form podcasts so to speak so well
it's interesting because the way we've
been approaching this is the you know
two hour and a half two sometimes three
hour-long podcasts right those are what
we dish out and then with patreon we're
like oh here's a bonus question and it's
like a 10 minute episode yeah and it's
like you know looking at that model it
seems inverse yeah yeah and well I would
have noticed is people really like for
last month or so we've been doing a
little bit longer episodes on patreon 20
30 40 minute episodes of patron and
people on our patreon items really
really enjoy that and because you know
you're able to listen to the minimalist
private podcast feed in your normal
podcast player and it really does feel
like it's just it feels looser and it
feels like oh yeah we're just having
this conference I remember the first
tour we did back in 2011 and like 20
people gather around and we never felt
too self-conscious about we were saying
we're just having these conversations
with this group of people instead of a
million people who might be listening to
the podcast and so we want to be able to
think out loud in front of a small group
of people who are willing to give us the
leeway to grow and fail and change our
minds in real time and we need to be
able to talk about our our failed habits
our family lives you know things like we
talked about your dad and I'm sure we'll
dive deeper in today's PostScript
episode yeah our struggles our personal
relationships our emotions our
insecurities without fear of judgment or
a public ridicule right I mean the thing
is yeah judgement is obviously real but
there are some real sensitive things we
want to be able to talk about right and
so we believe that patreon is the
place for us to delve into sensitive
subjects difficult discussions and
occasionally lighten things up with with
our chowderheaded tomfoolery we think
we're funny and patreon is the patreon
his best way for us to fund our podcast
as well and keep it 100% advertisement
free because that's one thing that we
agreed on from the beginning we don't
want to just pepper and a whole bunch of
advertisements about mattresses and
underwear and stuff it's not us judging
other people for doing that it doesn't
align with what we want to produce here
so this is a great way for us to to make
the podcast 100 percent advertisement
free and then also keep the the main
feed free for for everyone who wants to
indulge in that so next month
it's a February 2019 the minimalist
podcast the the main the main feed is
taking a month off we're taking a month
off from the public podcasts so we're
still going to record for private
podcast episodes for our patreon
audience in in February so if you want
to listen to the podcast still support
our show in February the only place to
do that will be on patreon because we're
gonna take the month off from the
minimalists feed the four episodes that
we're going to and we could really use
your questions patreon supporters we
could we're gonna record four episodes
one about products one about happiness
one about branding so the products one
is sort of like what products do we find
value in but then also what products are
we being sold that we think we get value
from and we've got some really good
articles to to discuss in these as well
the happiness episode there's some
science some new science about happiness
and what makes us happy and I want to
talk about that with Orion and see if we
agree or disagree on that the branding
episode we've been there's some
interesting stuff going on with branding
recently and the advertisers who sell
these brands to us and some questions I
have about you know I think all of us
are brands to some extent now sure
and we're branding ourselves online
we're trying to put our best foot
forward you know follow me on twitter at
jfm this is my brand but is it authentic
and what is authentic even meaning in
today's world right and also we're going
to have
gentrification which is a very sensitive
subject but now I've got some really
great articles to to discuss in some
places it's a really big problem in some
places it is the opposite of a problem
like you actually have to hope for
gentrification let's talk about why why
it may it may be useful in certain
places so we're gonna do this for
episode so if you have questions about
these topics you can leave them for us
on on patreon then beginning in March
after we take the month off of the main
podcast the minimalist podcasts the the
popular free public version will return
with 30-minute episodes so shorter
episodes using the same format so
similar to our current format we're
gonna answer voicemail questions we have
lightning round questions added value
right here right now just going to be
more attenuated we're gonna call these a
minimal episode and we're gonna try and
do it in less than thirty minutes every
week and in doing so it's that creative
restraint we might build something
beautiful and strange that a lot of
people will actually asked for this and
write large chunks of our audience have
asked hey why don't you make the episode
shorter I know I've been snarky instead
well it's it's as short as you want it
to be it's never gonna be short enough
for everyone that's not the reason we're
doing it but it is going to help some
people were like I really would love to
have a 30-minute episode every week
instead of these two hour behemoths yeah
but if you want an additional episode on
top of that that's what we're gonna do
everything else is on patreon so each
week we'll record an additional 60 plus
minute episode on patreon and about the
topic we're discussing that week so
maybe we're doing a discussion about
decluttering right and so we'll do the
30 minute episode about decluttering but
then we'll to have deep into patrons
questions and there'll be a few
different tiers and more details on on
that coming soon we're gonna call those
longer episodes 60 plus minutes it might
be 90 minutes there might be two hours
who knows how long we'll go we'll call
those the maximal episodes and so if you
want the free minimum or you still get
that you still get our podcast do you
download it you listen to it still be a
hundred percent advertisement free and
if you want to dive deep with us and
enjoy some of these more intimate
conversations you can do that as well
we're also going to add a new segment
this is Ryan's idea it's a segment
called more about less each week during
our patreon only maximal up
so we'll read about a current event that
ties directly or indirectly to
minimalism then we'll share our opinions
and because Ryan and I both have
different points of view sometimes
radically different points of view
politically or keeps it interesting many
exactly it's it's not just us we're not
parroting each other we have parody with
a lot of things in our life because we
have the same values but we have
different beliefs different points of
view politically and spiritually and
emotionally
so we'll probably disagree on many of
the topics we discuss over there on
patreon but I'm sure you won't mind if
mommy and daddy argue a little bit as
long as we we hug it out afterwards we
got more details coming next month on
these patreon episodes if you're
interested and signing up for that you
can head on over right now to the
minimalists comm slash support you can
find a link to our patreon account there
or you can go directly to patreon it's
just patreon.com slash the minimalist we
really appreciate your support show amen
all right what else do we have here you
can comment on this episode today at
youtube.com slash the minimalist
speaking of YouTube or ending season 2
of living room conversations they were
50 episodes in the living room
conversations the first season was 30
episodes second season about 20 or 21
episodes and you can go catch up on all
those now we may embark on a season 3 is
sometime in the future I don't know when
the the theme of this year is subtract
for us so when we're finding ways to
subtract or in fact we're gonna do an
episode about subtracting and really
that that's what we're looking to do is
subtract a little bit so we're pulling
back on living room conversations for a
while there's 50 of them out there if
you haven't seen all 50 of them now's
the time for you to go back and find the
ones that interest you most youtube.com
slash the minimalist if you want our
show notes and your email INBOX sign up
for our e-mail list over at the
minimalists comm and you'll also receive
our simple sundays emails each week
we've got some tips or essays or
different writings about simplicity each
week over at the minimalists com just go
there enter your email address at the
top and speaking of simple it's your
last chance to sign up for a simple year
it's 12 months of guided simplicity if
you go to the minimalists comm slash
simple year it's a course with 12
different experts Ryan
I guess it's 13 experts because you and
I are did we do one month so the the 12
months of guided simplicity 12 different
topics throughout 2019 and it's a last
chance
January's last chance to sign up the
minimalists comm / simple year of course
I don't think you need to sign up you
don't need a book or a course to
simplify your life but if you feel like
you need a little bit of help then maybe
12 months of guided simplicity is for
you Ryan
what else you got for us as always I
just want to encourage people to read
more and get informed and now here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hi guys my
name is Ian and I'm from Boston Mass I
have a tip for a caller named John who
was on the hope podcast he said he
wasn't noticing any benefits from
decluttering my advice to him would be
to you know once the room is decluttered
cleaned and rid of all the junk just
simply just be present in that room and
to really take it all in take your mind
away from the mental chatter and simply
just be in the space that you
decluttered that helped me really notice
the calm and you know decluttered space
around me hey Josh and Ryan my name is
Donovan for Packer in Ohio and I've been
practicing minimalism since about five
years ago after an enlightening bout
with bedbugs
perhaps a story for another time I'm
calling in with a tip for other
listeners who struggle with items that
they love but don't see as practical I
have a special category for these items
I refer to them as wings that make my
heart sing for example as a part of my
wardrobe I own a holiday sweater that
can really only be worn during Christmas
time and a bow tie that I get to wear
maybe half a dozen times a year I could
probably replace these with something
more practical or get rid of them
altogether but every time I think about
or see these items I smile and my heart
swells up with joy it seems so for me
these things don't necessarily bring
value in their immediate practicality
but instead they bring value in the form
of joy because I only own a handful of
these items I'm able to get true joy out
of you
each and every one of these things that
make my heart sing hi this is Kristin
and Nashville and I had a comment for
Sarah who's in Salt Lake City and moving
to San Francisco and there was a
solution for her to store the things she
loves and there was a solution for her
to get rid of them and also at one point
you all said you maybe invest in
expensive furniture that you would keep
if you wanted to do that and as a mom of
twin boys who are now 10 and the
daughter who's 11 I would say that if
you're going to buy a new furniture at
this point in your life
IKEA would be the way to go it has great
aesthetics and I know it's not the best
but your kids are going to tear up your
furniture so I wouldn't invest in
anything nice at this point unless
you're away stricter parent than I am
and keep your kids in line on the
furniture but anyway I just wanted to
throw that out there because you can
have a great looking house that will
temporarily get you through the kid
years for not a lot of money and then
you can get the expensive stuff that you
love
all right Jo that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalist or if you have a tip for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine or
you can email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm and if you leave
here with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
Shawn won't we play them out here with
greater Charlotte by Michael Flynn
unless you're on YouTube then click
somewhere right here
in lists